Alright, tomorrow night.
You, me, party
What up, C?
Bee, call us if there's any trouble, okay?
Cole, don't cause any trouble
I bet Bee has boys over at your place all the time
That's what babysitters do!
Seriously, have you ever been awake
after she's fallen asleep?
I love her
Oh man! Three out of four people got a STD!
I got two people's blood on me!
You do the math!
911?
My babysitter is trying to kill me
Are the attackers in the house?
They're downstairs having a blast
Alrighty babes, let's head upstairs
and get the blood of the innocent
This would go viral.
I mean, nobody's done human sacrifice
People have always done human sacrifice
Yeah, but, like, not in America
with hot people
Hey!
Hi Cole!
Not weird, we're just having fun
Things get messy
when you make a deal with the devil
Why is he shirtless?
That's your first question?
There's only one way to end this, Cole
Fuck you!
Titty down!
Oh my God, he shot me in the boob!
What kind of dick shoots a girl in the boob?
You guys suck
You crazy, bitch!